[Musique]
merci beaucoup et bien bonsoir à toutes
et à tous j'ai l'immense responsabilité
d'ouvrir en tant que premier
conférencier et donc j'aurais aimé en
effet vous présentez vous parlez du
design donc en effet je m'appelle
geoffrey est en effet je suis designer
alors le design c'est quelque chose qui
est ma passion quelque chose qui m'anime
et j'adore parler de ma patiente les
gens qui me sont proches les gens qui
sont mes amis ma famille etc
et quand je parle avec eux j'essaye de
savoir un petit peu pour eux qu'est ce
que c'est que le design à leurs yeux
dans dans leur coeur ce qu'ils en
pensent et c est très souvent on parle
de ça on parle d' objets alors d objet
élégant des objets qui parfois valent
cher des objets esthétiques des objets
qui parfois ne sont pas très pratique
pour ceux qui ont déjà eu la chance
d'utiliser ce presse agrumes car c'est
un presse agrumes parfois également
quand je parle avec d'autres sur
l'action du design on parle de ça aussi
l'esthétique la typographie quand tout
est bien aligné quand c'est un peu
vintage et c'est moi j'aime bien mais je
dis non c'est pas que ça le design ça me
parle pas uniquement
juste ça suffit pas et puis aussi on
parle de ça en me disant voilà un
designer c'est ça c'est quelqu'un qui a
une façon d'être ski à la mode c'est un
style de vie etc
et c est pareil j'ai pas cette barbe et
je me reconnais pas là-dedans
peut-être y en a certains d'entre vous
qui ont ces lunettes de soleil mais
malgré tout pour mâles design ça ça ne
suffit pas quand c'est comme ça parfois
encore et ça brise mon coeur j'entends
le mot c'est design
alors ça c'est terrible le nom parce que
le mot design c'est un nom ça vient de
dizaines you de l'italien qui veut dire
le dessin fait de dessiner mais aussi le
dessin à la volonté de faire quelque
chose c'est un très beau mot ça devient
un adjectif qui veut dire ouais c'est
design cette voiture lé design
ouais cette presse agrumes et les design
etc devient un objectif pour dire c'est
joli c'est bien fait
peut-être ça coûte cher donc c'est
design non ça me suffit pas donc quand
ça me suffit pas comme ça j'ai demandé à
quelqu'un qui c'est plein de choses qui
sait presque tout j'ai demandé à google
alors google
j'ai demandé ce que c'était que le
design alors voilà ce qu'il m'a répondu
le design by sais pas non plus deuxième
vie c'est quoi super ensuite il me parle
de design c'est l' aventure me voilà
bien avancés et ensuite il me parle du
responsive design du flat design etc
autant de modes de tendances et de
choses qui sont aussi dans l'air du
temps et qui parce qu'ils sont parfois à
la mode
je continue dans mon exploration sur
google là je demande voilà un objet
design qu'est ce que c'est qu'un objet
de design et la bomba voilà il me répond
également design célèbre suite dans la
célébrité en bois déco pas cher autant
d'adjectifs qui ne suffisent pas non
plus quand on parle du design et puis la
dernière question que j'ai posée à
google si c'est parce que c'est que le
design s qui sait ce que c'est qu'un
designer alors là la première question
qui me pose qui est le designer à
l'origine de la freebox révolution à ce
que certains d'entre vous le savent
voilà bien vous le savez parce que
forcément on retourne dans la célébrité
la mode le côté voilà c'est philippe
starck le designer le plus connu francs
en france en tout cas et beaucoup aussi
dans le monde et ça me suffit pas et
puis quand je descends un qui peut vous
voyez le designer et il est responsable
de ce qu'il produit et là je suis ça y
est google à une question intéressante
imposé et c'est cette question là que
j'aimerais ont développé ensemble et
c'est un petit peu ma quête du design
pour essayer de comprendre le design
pour essayer de la de me l'approprier et
ben il part de cette question là on est
responsable de ce qu'on produit alors
cette quête j'aimerais vous la présentez
partager avec vous quelques unes de ses
réflexions et puis tout d'abord pour moi
le design c'est l'observation c'est vous
scrutez comme ça c'est observer votre
quotidien s'est observée aux usages pour
façon de faire etc
et puis le point de vue de designers
c'est aussi un regard sur le monde
l'observation alors je temps plein de
photos l'observation c'est ça par
exemple
là j'étais avec des amis à nantes
partait ça faisait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas vu la mer on arrive hop
damien iehl fait une vidéo en live avec
sa femme et ses enfants
il y ai regardé la mer c'est sympa
guerrier mais elle est en train de
publier une photo sur instagram est rom
est en train de publier une photo sur
facebook et puis moi je les prends en
photo je vous dis voilà on est dans des
situations où on a un paysage magnifique
et âme dans le partage certains
trouveraient ça terrible parce qu'en
profitent pas et d'autres pourraient
trouvé ça passionnant parce que tout à
coup on partage des choses à ceux qui ne
les ont pas ça ça m'intrigue
ça me possède et je me dis il ya quelque
chose derrière autre exemple
l'autre joueur à l'arrêt de bus jeune
femme qui reçoit un coup de fil est très
élégamment église son téléphone dans son
voile et je me dis elle vient de
s'improviser un kit mains libres en une
seconde comme ça hop
rien n'a été conçu pour elle le fait
elle parle je suis sûr certains d'entre
vous peut être on déjà vu cette façon de
faire je trouve ça fascinant
autre exemple voilà ces deux personnes
qui ont pris une table des chaises qui
au bord d'un canal monter l'échelle se
sont installés avec du café et elles
sont posées elle installe un espace qui
est le leur et rien n'a été conçu pour
ça rien été pensé pour ça elle
s'approprie un univers est le détourne
et ça moi ça me fascine aussi ça me
fascine aussi de voir des jeunes filles
qui se remaquille avec leur téléphone
dans le métro dans un café etc
je sais que certains d'entre vous l'ont
déjà fait j'en suis sûr et tout à coup
c'est génial on n'a pas de miroir et
voilà puis dans les observations aussi
l'obsession du quotidien mais ceux ci
deux observations dans certaines
situations
par exemple ici ce sont des personnes
réfugiées très souvent on dit voilà les
personnes réfugiées ont besoin de
nourriture ont besoin d'argent et c'est
eux ils ont besoin de communiquer et
leur communication est face elle passe
en fait par l'électricité par le fait de
se connecter
donc tout à coup il ramène des prises
ils ramènent leurs chargeurs ils
partagent tout ça et ça chauffe ça beau
je trouve ça intéressant et julie a des
choses à faire derrière ça et puis voilà
pour moi le design aussi c'est aussi
aller observer des situations sociales
de partage des enfants qui vont
expliquer à leurs grands-parents et puis
aussi de transmission transmission du
savoir aussi dans les deux sens
alors voilà pour moi faire du design
c'est d'abord penser aux autres c'est
penser à l'autre c'est la vérité c'est
l'empathie empathie c'est un mot très
beau hein l'empathie c'est ya pathos
dedans pathos c'est la souffrance
or quand j'ai parfois je parle avec mes
étudiants je leur dit soyez empathique
vous êtes designer soyez empathique je
leur dise souffrait avec vous les
personnes pour qui vous crée alors le
disent ne pas souffrir on n'y a pas que
ça dans le pathos y aussi le fait de se
mettre à la place de l'autre et ça c'est
important et donc penser à l'autre
et quand je vous dit penser à l'autre en
fait c'est penser à vous pensez à vos
usages pensez à votre façon d'interagir
penser à ce qui vous anime aussi allés
observer qu' qui les autres qu'ils sont
réellement
et puis les autres on a des mots pour
parler des autres alors parfois dans des
réunions ça doit vous arriver j'entends
parler de consommateurs de clients
d'usagé de cibles dont on a même parfois
parler de target
comme si on était des cibles à abattre
c'est plutôt notre portefeuille qui
sembleraient à abattre de bénéficiaires
ou encore d'acheteurs bref autant de
mots qui définissent les gens pour
qu'ils ont créée pour qui on fait les
choses pour qui on passe énormément
d'énergie et moi c'est mowlem
conviennent pas à ces mots là je
préfèrerais des mots comme lecteur
utilisateurs citoyens personnes acteurs
ou encore humain et pour moi c'est ça
qui est important c'est c'est un regard
politique ça regard engagé que le design
doit avoir c'est de dire voilà on va
faire des choses pour les gens et du
moment où déjà on met des mots sur ces
personnes là on a déjà une action
on a déjà un premier pas vers l'autre et
une fois qu'on sait vers qui on veut
aller commencer à définir les mots on a
commencé à regarder les gens moi c'est
ça qui m'anime aussi c'est que en fait
ça vous est déjà arrivé mais offrir un
cadeau à quelqu'un pour noël à quelqu'un
qui a déjà tout vous creuser la tête
vous trouvez pas d'idée c'est compliqué
ouais mais il a sa wii mais il aime ça
mais il possède déjà tous ces terribles
et j'ai pas envie de faire du design en
fait pour les gens qui ont déjà tout et
en parlant politique justement quand on
parle de gens qui ont déjà tous
aujourd'hui on a
soixante deux personnes ça rapporte de
l'oxfam qui détiennent autant que la
moitié de la population mondiale et je
n'ai absolument pas envie de me lever le
matin de consacrer du temps de l'énergie
pour ses soixante de personnes sachant
qu'il ya 7 milliards et quelques qui
attendent qu'ils ont besoin qui exprime
pas forcément ses besoins et qui pour
qui on peut faire de belles choses
et donc voilà je voulais vous parler un
petit peu de mes clients pour reprendre
ce mot que j'ai écrit un petit peu tout
à l'heure et en fait moi je travaille
pour des clients qui sont à la mode ça
c'est vraiment chouette
les clients à la mode on entend beaucoup
parler à la radio à la télé on en entend
parler dans la presse etc et je voulais
vous les présenter parce que c'est des
clients qui ont besoin du design ses
clients à la mode
là ce sont les personnes réfugiées eux
ont besoin du design terriblement
énormément et en entend beaucoup parler
et hélas c'est à la mode
entente y beaucoup parlé des personnes
âgées des personnes en situation de
handicap eux ont besoin du design
également en temps si beaucoup parlé des
jeunes
je travaille aussi avec le design pour
les jeunes j'ai besoin d'études qui ont
besoin d'apprendre qu'ils ont besoin de
la transmission du savoir ou encore des
gens qui ont besoin d'eau apporter l'eau
dans certains pays où c'est compliqué
c'est hyper important
ou encore ça peut tout simplement des
citoyens des citoyens qui s'unissent
dans des situations important des
situations de crise des situations de
mal-être sur des besoins aussi qui
n'exprime pas forcément eh ben toutes
ces personnes tous ses clients pour les
reprendre avec des guillemets ben moi
j'aime travailler pour elle pour eux et
pourrait donc pour vous illustrer
maintenant après vous avoir présenté un
petit peu les différentes facettes et
différentes personnes pour qui le design
se doit d'agir vous présenter quelques
petits projets que j'ai réalisé des
projets que j'estime être engagée pour
les gens premier projet c'est un projet
très simple que j'ai fait quand j'étais
chercheur en design
c'est un projet qui s'appelle nine et
qui va chercher à communiquer autrement
communiquer plus par les émotions parce
qu'aujourd'hui on envoie des sms on
s'appelle on envoie des on envoie des
emails tout est très formalisé formelle
et je me suis dit qu'avec ce petit cette
petite application très simple on va
pouvoir écrire un petit message
la glisser dans une enveloppe et
l'avenir la glisser sur le bord de son
téléphone et le récepteur va recevoir
sur le bord de son téléphone à lui un
petit message qui va attraper c'est
assez simple en fait c'est une façon de
s'amuser avec la conversation s'amuser
avec la discussion mais tout à coup si
dans mon petit message j'écris par
exemple je pense à toi je le mets dans
ma petite enveloppe je glisse ce bout de
cinq minutes je vois que la personne n'a
pas prise bon bah je peux reprendre mon
petit message puis je peux changer où je
peux le supprimer et c'est ce qu'on peut
jouer avec cette temporalité 7 messager
ce message est aussi un peu de la
sincérité quand on exprime quelque chose
c'était un premier point de départ un
deuxième point de départ ensuite pour
les pour les personnes âgées
quand on a aujourd'hui des personnes
âgées c'est très difficile de leur
demander
bon alors raconte nous raconte ou
comment c'était avant raconte tout avis
c'est compliqué alors ce qu'on a fait
c'est un projet qui s'appelle ligne de
mémoire c'est très simple c'est tout
simplement une frise chronologique avec
sur la droite un espace pour les
personnes âgées elles peuvent manipuler
avec leurs petits-enfants leurs enfants
avec des parfois quand ce sont des
établissements pour pour les personnes
âgées peuvent travailler aussi ça avec
les gens et puis dans cet espace elle va
pouvoir enregistrer du son taper un peu
de texte mettre une photo etc et pour
déclencher toutes ces mémoires tous ces
éléments souvenirs en face et des
archives de l'ina et les archives de la
presse il ya les unes de journaux de
l'époque etc etc
autant d'éléments qui vont venir un
petit peu nourrir résister nous faire
nous rappeler des choses et ça ça a
fonctionné parce que justement il y
avait sept éléments de départ
un autre exemple encore je vous parlais
de personnes réfugiées tout à l'heure ça
c'est un projet très simple c'est pour
faire en sorte que les personnes qui
sont j'aime pas trop qu'on les appelle
réfugiés d'ailleurs il appelle nouveaux
arrivants immigrés parfois qui arrive
comme ça pour oser franchir la porte
d'une boutique d'un magasin d'un
appartement si parfois de coller comme
ça des petits autocollants avec des
petits symboles
vous voyez ici bienvenue aux réfugiés et
puis en dessous on peut présenter pas
qu'on peut offrir du wifi vous pouvez
offrir de la musique pour offrir un café
vous pouvez offrir un coup de téléphone
par exemple et c'est donc à plein de
petites choses qu'on peut faire et c'est
un premier pas
vers lesquels on peut amorcer pour
rencontrer des réfugiés
et puis un autre projet à nouveau pour
les réfugiés s'est réfugié jive c'est un
projet que j'ai fait récemment
là encore c'est pour les personnes
réfugiées parce que je partis du constat
qu'il y avait beaucoup de difficultés
dans la communication entre les réfugiés
les administrations et des citoyens tout
simplement et on parle pas forcément
anglais arabe français la communication
est très difficile donc l'idée de cette
application c'est très simple c'est
d'avoir des pictogrammes que vous voyez
ici et on va pouvoir les drag and drop
et les déplacés sur sur cet écran ils
vont s'agrandir on va pouvoir les bars
et emploiera entouré on va pouvoir
écrire par dessus voir faire des flèches
etc etc
et l'idée comme ça c'est de pouvoir
justement faciliter la communication
ça remplace pas bien évidemment tout le
langage mais arriver à expliquer des
situations qui sont parfois délicate
difficile parler d'homosexualité parler
d'eux de maltraitance parler aussi de
besoin d'un passeport pour quelqu'un de
sa famille qui restait dans un pays etc
c'est autant de situations qui sont
difficiles et qui sont lourdes et avec
ces éléments là ces pictogrammes ces
images c'est parfois beaucoup plus
simple je voulais vous montrer aussi
voilà un autre exemple
enfin un dernier projet et c'est un des
plus récents c'est un projet qui
s'appelle hackers citizen et c'est un
projet très simple je me suis dit je
vais faire un livre pour les citoyens
pour les citoyens qui veulent se
réapproprier un peu bas la ville la rue
remettre de la culture dans la rue
remettre un petit peu de nature dans la
rue pour pouvoir aussi partager son
savoir partager des films partager des
livres partager plein de choses et dans
ce livre en fait à chaque fois c'est une
des illustrations qui viennent raconter
un petit peu et puis ces petites
explications un petit tutoriel qui va
venir expliquer aux citoyens faire ça
que ses enfants faire ça en famille peut
faire ça tout seul le week-end par
exemple comme petite recette très simple
avec des étapes et surtout l'idée de
derrière derrière se livre à coeur
citizen sait comment pouvoir à quai ces
accords vont pouvoir aller plus loin a
parlé dépassé on va pour les détourner
ou alors c'est approprié
c'est un petit livre très simple et un
livre que j'estime être citoyen
donc voilà non tout simplement moi je
voulais surtout vous remercier vous là
pour vos tic vos habitudes vos valeurs
aux façons de faire vos façons d'avoir
des besoins des envies etc tous ces
éléments qui sont pour vous votre
quotidien
pour moi c'est hyper important de les
observer et me dire voilà et des beaux
projets à faire il est très très belles
choses à faire et aussi je voulais vous
partagez cette idée qui encore mille des
milliers de situations sociales hyper
importante parfois des situations
sociales de crise parfois des situations
sociales du quotidien autant de
situations sociales qui restent à
résoudre qui reste à travailler qui
reste à réfléchir sur lesquels il faut
réfléchir et si vous savez pas forcément
par quel bout vous y prendre tout
d'abord il va falloir observer ces
situations sociales identifier ensuite
les comprendre et ensuite essayer d'agir
à son échelle petites ou grandes peu
importe pour voir un petit peu le
changement politique est aussi citoyen
c'est hyper important que vous voulez
voir autour de vous et donc pour moi
c'est ça en fait être designer et c'est
aussi ça faire du design
voilà je remercie beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]